[Music]
fantastic beasts fan will be able to see
the third part the secrets of dumbledore
in theaters here on april 15th in our
latest original we talk about the plot
cast and production as well as
everything else you need to know about
the upcoming movie
first let's get to the plot of fantastic
beasts the secrets of dumbledore at this
point there's a risk of spoilers for the
first two parts as well we will of
course also briefly discuss the events
in these movies at the center of the
fantastic beasts series is of course
still newt's commander the british magi
zoologist in the first installment we
see nude arrive in new york city in 1926
with his suitcase in it are all sorts of
animals he was able to find on his
journey including a niffler and his
bowtruckles one quickly notices that the
mood in the city is very tense as more
and more prejudice and hostility from
the population builds up against the
magical society operating in secret
things get even worse when muggle jacob
kowalski accidentally opens nude
suitcase which is why some of the
animals escape thus he ensures that
chaos takes its course when they try to
recapture the animals together with two
witch sisters they have to face
dangerous opponents the plot of the
second part follows more or less
directly from the first
but as the title already reveals takes
care of the villain geller grindelwald
the dark wizard's ambitious goal is to
control the muggles through pure blood
wizards his plans quickly become serious
when grindelwald's with the help of
abernathy escapes during a prisoner
transfer and quickly gathers a
considerable number of followers around
him newt is eventually contacted by
albus dumbledore and asked to take out
the cause and fall grindelwald's plans
in paris the second part did not really
cause much enthusiasm among the fan
community and apart from a convincing
performance by johnny depp will
definitely not go down the analyst of
the movie history in contrast to the
first part which was mostly received
positively many seem to see a downgrade
in fantastic beasts the crime of
grindelwald warner brothers and the team
responsible therefore seem to be doing
everything they can to make the third
part more elaborate and epic fittingly
former warner boss kevin sushihara also
commented in an interview with the los
angeles times in 2019 where he clarified
that the second part did not do as well
as the first and then everything must be
done to make the third movie even better
than the first but can you even guess
what jk rowling and her support steve
cloves have put down on paper all the
time by the way cloves was also involved
in writing the screenplays for all of
the harry potter movies except order of
the phoenix in fact there are no exact
details about this story yet it seems
only this much is clear the story of
newt will not end after the third part
it has always been clear that the movie
series will consist of five parts at the
end of which the big showdown between
albus dumbledore and his former friend
gala grindelwald will take place in
1945. accordingly fantastic beasts the
secrets of dumbledore will be the exact
middle of the story arc and as we
already know from a 2018 tweet from
rowling the journey in the upcoming
movie even goes to far away rio de
janeiro for knowledgeable harry potter
fans this of course rings a bell after
all the magical school castle brooks is
also located in brazil which could
accordingly be illuminated in greater
detail dumbledore as the title suggests
is also to move more into focus his role
as a wise principal and mentor which is
present in the harry potter series
especially in the first six movies is
already questioned somewhat in fantastic
beasts too so we can expect to learn
more about dumbledore's dark side in the
upcoming installment as well actor jew
law also confirmed to facet of the
wizard in an interview with cinema blend
according to this he feels a certain
fashion towards nude because he takes
care of various beasts and albus thinks
of himself as a beast who has done dark
things
we are definitely curious to see whether
jude law can convincingly portray
dumbledore's character in the third part
the cast of fantastic beasts 3 is
definitely worth seeing besides main
actor eddie redmayne's nudes commander
there are some old and new characters to
see these are shown particularly vividly
by the fantastic beasts twitter channel
ss published some pictures of the actors
on the course of the second trailer
included for example are as ramila as
credence barebone jude law as albus
dumbledore kathleen waterson as tina
goldstein allison soodle as queenie
ghost in callum turner as theseus
commander and then fogler as jacob
kowalski the most controversial
personnel by far is of course the
casting of matt's mickelson as the
villain gala grindelwald the dark wizard
was embodied by johnny depp in parts 1
and 2 and suspended by warner brothers
for the planned filming of the third
part in the course of his court case
against amber heard walnut brothers
feared bad coverage if they held on to
death and preferred to pay him the
contractually guaranteed 16 million
dollar fee instead of continuing to plan
with him it was quickly decided that
matt's mickelson would take deb's place
many fans agree that this was wasn't
equally successful casting but they
would have liked to see a fair approach
to johnny depp and his ex-wife amber
heard either way the demands on matt's
mickelson's grindelwald will be enormous
but the 56 year old dane was surely
aware of that beforehand
the filming of fantastic beasts the
secrets of dumbledore turned out to be
extremely difficult after they were
supposed to begin in summer 2019 they
were postponed until february 2020 when
the pandemic threw a spanner in the
works after further cancellations in the
meantime filming was not finally
completed until may 2021 behind the
scenes director david yates is
responsible who has already celebrated
great success with his staging of not
only fantastic beasts but also of harry
potter but he was also provided with an
impeccable template by j.k rowling
because the best-selling author was in
charge of writing the screenplay in
addition to rowling david heyman is also
responsible for the production the 60
year old is one of the leading months
behind the wizarding world and has
co-produced all eight harry potter
movies as well as the two fantastic
beasts parts so warner brothers is going
with a tried and true hero which should
certainly please fans
finally we briefly analyzed the two
trailers that have been released so far
the very first teaser was followed by
the first real trailer in december 2021
shortly before the 20th anniversary of
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone we
see many familiar characters such as
jacob youssef alba's brother aberforth
the teacher lily hicks and of course
nude for a change we also see places
outside of great britain such as
grindelwald's fortress normandgar in
austria as well as rio de janeiro and
china as you can guess from the
portuguese and chinese banners in the
trailer in addition nude will return to
new york and is believed that dumbledore
and credence will dwell in nazi germany
in the 1930s and 1940s and then the
viewers will also have noticed various
allusions to the harry potter movie
series after all the trailer begins
directly with a snitch above hogwarts
rooftops the second trailer was released
at the end of february and shows even
more from the finished movie here are
the two opposing factions of grindelwald
and dumbledore in the foreground on
grindelwald's style these are mainly
mind reader queenie and credence who as
we know develop into an obscurial since
direct confrontation is not an option
for albus due to the blood oath revealed
in part two he too has various comrades
and arms for the fight against
grindelwald dumbledore's first army as
it is called in a tweet from wizarding
world on february 22 consists of newt
his friend jacob as well as professor
lally a newt's assistant bunty
that's it again with our new original we
hope you're now well prepared fantastic
beasts the secrets of dumbledore will be
released in u.s movie theaters on april
15th 2022. see you next time
[Music]